the great thing about this space is that
there's no red tape here if I have an
idea that I want to shoot I could just
[ __ ] do it it just takes time yeah
you know just takes my personal time
yeah there's I mean generally once you
have the equipment that that your
overheads already paid for once you
start making money I even think about
like even you mentioned like there's
there's a lot of content that you don't
like that's on YouTube but like the fact
that it's free and available for
somebody to put that content out is
important yeah because it allows for in
five four three two one what's up
everybody Welcome to a another episode
of The Genius brain podcast how are
y'all doing today if this is your first
time uh uh listening in just to let you
know you either might love me you might
hate me but you're still listening you
stupid [ __ ] and today we got a very
special guest listen you guys know I've
been on this like really interesting tip
of um
bringing a lot of people that you guys
don't know
um especially in my world and I'll tell
you right now the person that you're
about to see once I flip the camera back
onto him is somebody I haven't seen in
10 [ __ ] years yeah bro 10 plus
[ __ ] years and I know I talk a lot
about where I'm from like Sacramento is
a it's a town that I'm super proud of
like I feel like a lot of people don't
understand the level of like Artistry
and talent that comes out of the city uh
and definitely Brandon here is one of
those people now I mean do you still go
buy sushi yeah I do
[ __ ] it go baby which is nuts man so
I've been bringing on a lot of artists
what whether it's stand-up comics or
just anybody that I really really [ __ ]
with and I was just telling him that the
people that were connected with like
Loosely is how I found him again because
uh I follow a Rudy rain on if you guys
know him from a Quest Crew he's a dancer
also a musician also from Sacramento
yeah and years ago this motherfucker's
account got hacked
and he just kept spamming [ __ ] to me
so I blocked this dumbass I was like
you're done lo and behold got his
account back still see that he's doing
music he was doing music with Phil and
then I see this motherfucker's face and
I'm like what the [ __ ] has this guy been
up to so years ago in Sacramento I
actually started off as a [ __ ]
musician I wanted to do music and there
was this whole like scene in Sacramento
where like I feel a lot of these like
Indie artists were popping up right yeah
when it came to music whether it was
dance or whatever type of Art and then
this [ __ ] was also a part of the
scene and he is and was a rapper yeah
and I was like what the [ __ ] is sush
been up to and you know what the reason
why I brought you on this pod was
because I read a post on your Instagram
where
um I didn't know that music wasn't your
main focus for a while you wanted to
start getting back into it yeah which
for me was kind of like I've been kind
of going through that same thing and
it's a little hard for me to hear
sometimes specifically because for
somebody like you like to me you were
one of the most talented people that I
met at the time and so when I hear
somebody who I personally feel is like
somebody that I Champion go I haven't
been back on my craft I started to think
what the [ __ ] has this guy been up to
like what have you been going through to
feel like you haven't
pursued your talent that I that I and a
lot of people around you really feel
like this is your thing
well it's interesting because I already
kind of like gave you like a little bit
of like trinkling in on some of those
things as we were kind of like stepping
in here but the
a lot of it had to do with
around
2012 2013
I stepped into a completely different
realm of music that I was not prepared
for I don't think
um especially because when you met me it
was at the height of this underground
hip-hop scene that was taking over this
is at like the beginning of when Odd
Future was going on this is when all of
the blog era rap stuff was happening and
so there was almost like this rallying
cry against radio especially from
Sacramento's hip-hop scene and a lot of
California's hip-hop scene at the time
um and so during that time frame I ended
up working in radio which is really
weird
how weird is that [ __ ] it's like [ __ ]
radio what do you do I work for radio
yeah but the thing that was kind of cool
about that too was even when I got hired
at the radio station I didn't get like
the hate on that side of it which it
could have definitely felt like that but
instead
the whole Community rallied behind it
like yo one of us got in it was like a
almost like an infiltration kind of
thing but during that time frame I
started really putting all of my
creative energy into radio because it
was my way of having this nostalgic feel
of what it was like for me to listen to
those radio stations growing it up
because I was working at the station
that I grew up as the I grew up with as
the hip-hop station in Sacramento it was
formerly 103.5 The Bomb which which is
not anymore which is not anymore it's
also not hot 103.5 which it was when I
was there oh what does it know it's uh
Fuego 1019 what the [ __ ] so in
Sacramento there was like two stations a
102.5 and 103.5 yeah and that's where
you would hear either it's like the pop
[ __ ] or hip-hop [ __ ] and that's about it
yeah and people would always go back and
forth from those two stations yeah and
when I had gotten to 103.5 it had
shipped it had shifted into a full-on
pop station for a little bit and their
logo looked like a ripoff of the hostess
logo it would really get the [ __ ] out of
here it was bad bro why what do that
because they burnt out during the hyphy
movement so when hyphy was getting
really big in Northern California being
for those who don't know what hyphy is
it is the Northern California staple of
party music and it was this entire and
outside of the music it became a whole
culture throughout Northern California
um and the program director at that
station went too hard on it and scared
away all of the investors and AD folks
and so when that happened they had to
figure out a brand new plan and they cut
it and turn it into a pop station what
the [ __ ] yo that haifi movement stage
was wild yeah like I remember first
hearing like Mac Dre right and then when
Mac Dre was like on and I was like I
didn't like it at first I was like the
[ __ ] is this and the next thing you know
I'm just I love it bro I feel the exact
same way today because again I was the
backpack rapper kid for so long yeah so
then when haifi was happening I was kind
of involved in it because I grew up in
it in high school but at the same time
as I was kind of like becoming this
quote unquote conscious rapper behind
all of that I was like
I hate all of this I can't stand that
people are ruining music like this now
everybody can make music and then as the
years went by I kind of started seeing
how important it was because songs like
tell me when to go and songs like super
hyphy where this really weird
phenomenon in Northern California where
I remember going to school dances and
tell me when to go would come on and
everybody it didn't matter if there was
like a goth kid that sat in the corner
during lunch it didn't matter if it was
the kids that are usually out playing
basketball together it didn't matter if
it was the group of nerds that ended up
playing magic cards at the lunch tables
they were going stupid in the middle of
the Dance Floor to tell me when to go
yeah and I remember that feeling and how
important that was and when I start
especially now reflecting on that that's
more important to me than any of the
other things I was feeling as what it
was doing two or four hip-hop at the
time
foreign
[Music]
wow I feel like I'm far beyond patient
running out of time but realizing I'm
just stumbling over my own laces
thinking I would get new tricks from old
faces and finding out they on new [ __ ] a
whole facelift learning that these
so-called friends was just acquaintances
baseless relationships faded when the
placements did if i'da knew better I
would do better maybe my mistake was
putting way too much maintenance in
maybe I'm insane cause I never change
[ __ ] maybe I'm a strange cause I need to
every day I pray for a better day and
every day the game gets more see-through
I made it to the Valley of the shadow of
death and though I see in here I won't
speak or fear those evils Bishop told me
that's the god in me and it means god in
me I should never fear those people I've
been on my last with a few times since
arrival one eye on the prize and the
other the wrong survival nobody's eye
but everyone's arrival so I'm done
Catching Feelings every time I know I'm
lied to I'm on to the next part in the
flex when you see me know that you're
looking at Art In the Flesh standing far
from the rest while I'm manifesting
greatness and tasting it will be my mark
of success at best I came here seeking
Vindication are at the very least
reciprocation for the love that I showed
at the radio station instead I got
another sign for me to turn over the
page then I feel like I've been far
beyond patient I'm done stumbling over
my own laces my old phase is nothing but
closed cases when I'm standing on the
top again you'll recognize my face then
[Music]
but at that point I remember when I went
to college right so music was very
separated at the time like if you were
in NorCal you didn't hear NorCal [ __ ] in
SoCal it just wasn't there and then I
just remember out of nowhere I heard
somebody bang like Max Ray like when I
was in SoCal I was like what the [ __ ] do
you know about this [ __ ] but this is
when music music started becoming Global
yeah right where you wouldn't hear like
oh this style stays here everybody this
is like the moment I specifically
remember where I started seeing rappers
just start taking a little bit of
everybody's influence because of the
internet yeah so now you hear like
people's like Cadence and flows start to
change up it's like oh that no longer is
like that's not drill [ __ ] anymore
that's everybody's [ __ ] yeah
and a lot of people kind of hate it some
people kind of like it right I feel like
for me I'm kind of like in between
because it allows people to kind of work
on their craft in so many different ways
but at the same time everything just
starts to sound the same yeah you know I
think one of the things that I did
appreciate though is like when I think
La is having that flavor right now where
people are really liking where it's that
La [ __ ] like gangster rap [ __ ] is
starting to come back a little bit yeah
and you're seeing their Style just like
back in the day we had the whole hyphy
movement in NorCal and that was our
thing and now a lot of people are like
yo what's this [ __ ] oh that's that Cali
rap type of [ __ ] yeah and a lot of
people are hopping onto it yeah it feels
good to see that happen again because I
think even like feeding off of the same
thing of just like the fact that so much
music was just kind of neutral for so
long it was kind of cool that that was
happening because it meant that anybody
from anywhere could pick up any style
but at the same time it made people also
kind of be a little bit more nostalgic
to what those Regional sounds were like
because that was almost the only place
where those Regional phenomenons were
happening is when you go down that
rabbit hole of nostalgia with all of
that and so now that anybody and
everybody does it it's kind of cool that
there's that blurred line where you know
somebody like Wiz Khalifa was out on out
in uh Pittsburgh making music that
sounded like he was working with Snoop
the whole time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was perfect it was a perfect blend of
that and I think I thought that was a
really cool phenomenon to happen yeah
man like it's weird where you know I
wonder if like for you especially
because you're a rapper like do you ever
get into this space where you start
thinking like because I always hear this
conversation when a new artist comes out
they go oh this [ __ ] like he
can't rap and like my definition of that
started changing a lot right or well I
think like objectively speaking right
there's some of these newer like for
example like uh
it's not called Lil yachty it's called a
little boat now he's a little old yeah
right I objectively think he cannot rap
right as a in in the terms of him being
a musician
but now like that definition of what a
of a good rapper is has changed right
like it's you don't have to be a
Lyricist anymore you don't have to do
this type of stuff but I remember like
it was the uh
it was a cipher that he was in it was
like it was like yeah I remember that
man bro it was like the Freshman The
Freshman XL whatever that [ __ ] made me
laugh so [ __ ] hard and then I thought
everybody was laughing with me and then
I read the comments that like see they
can rap I'm like wait hold on a second
I thought I thought we were all on the
same page like I thought we were on the
page that they can't rap and I'm not
saying they can't make good music yeah
those are two separate things you know
and I that's how I see it because it's
not like I don't enjoy that [ __ ] it's
not like if it's not bumping at the club
I'm not [ __ ] you know enjoying it I
thought that there was two separate
categories but I think like
you know sometimes when people say words
like oh this [ __ ] is like a
lyrical like conscious rapper it's
almost like a diss now yeah I'm like how
is that offensive like I I feel like I'm
old and [ __ ] you know what I mean I'm
like becoming an old head yeah you know
yeah I kind of was feeling that way too
and it was It was kind of scary
when I started really thinking about the
music that I was consuming because I was
like damn bro I think there's a lot of
people who are really dope but I'm just
starting to realize I have no idea what
they're talking about right
100 like I was uh I was listening me and
a homie were listening to smino one day
and we realized hey bro I still have
absolutely no idea what he's saying in
this music but he's dope to me somehow
man there are some times like I'll I'll
hear a line and I'm like and then I'll
look around to see how other people
react and then I'll see like a younger
crowd and I feel like even they know
that [ __ ] wasn't [ __ ] bars but
because they're looking around to see if
other people feel it they'll say it's
bars yeah and
you know I've said this to her some
people got really upset and I don't give
a [ __ ]
untalented people like to Champion other
untalented people because you want to be
in their place and sometimes it's hard
for me to like look at that [ __ ] right
because they'll know it's trash but
because they're like well he's trash I
know I'm not that good but if I say that
it's good then I could also be a part of
this Elite group because now we get to
decide what's dope even if it isn't
right objectively speaking well it can't
be objective but in my mind it's
objective anyways but that's why that's
how I feel about like Tick Tock it's
like Tick Tock is the app for uncreative
people to pretend that they're creative
yeah right so they look for something
that somebody else does they steal it
and they don't even recreate it at all
and then they get the views for it and
they get that endorphin rush from being
a creative yeah without having to be
creative
it's scary on that end as well because
the thing that I've been seeing lately
is now people are doing exactly that
they're taking what has already been
done and then figuring out ways to do
the exact same thing but figure out what
the next level up is and then you see
that it turns into so first we were
doing in our bedroom and now we're doing
it at this person's concert
and that's where Steve Lacy is in this
really weird have you seen what's
happening with that with Steve Lacy's
tour so basically
Steve Lacy has been going on tour
and every every show stop is sold out
but a large percentage don't know any of
the music except for this snippet from
tick tock
oh [ __ ] and then he'll perform that song
they'll sing the hook and then the
second verse comes on nothing dead
silent and he's even gotten to the point
where he's trolling the crowd about it
where he's said things like all right go
ahead sing the next verse ah you don't
know it and then just move on
how does that feel as a [ __ ] artist
bro that [ __ ] must be demoralizing as
[ __ ] yeah and it's because people aren't
really there for the artist it feels
like anymore they're there for
themselves
oh
yo that's so trippy because like
I wonder how that makes him feel right
yeah somebody who's out there that in
his mind goes I create dope [ __ ] but the
only thing people want to see is like oh
I know this tick tock song and he puts
out his whole discography and they don't
know a single [ __ ] word you know
this is what happens though like
when you have fast content
fast content isn't longevity you know
like you create I think this is I'm not
against these things but the reason why
people how come you don't do more shorts
how come you don't do these type of
things is because people expect to
consume your content on on a 30 minute
basis now yeah and if it doesn't hit
their endorphins in that first second
they don't care to be invested into it
like the the era of like long form long
format content aside from podcast people
just want their stuff really quick
when you see a lot of like Tick-Tock
people right
um and I'm not talking about like the
one percent of people who are really
successful and people know who they are
there are people on Tick Tock who have
millions and millions of [ __ ] views
and people don't know who the [ __ ] they
are yeah they literally don't know who
the [ __ ] they are they just go oh I
enjoyed that video they give it a like
LOL and they pass and they move on so
that that connection that they have with
their fan base and their art are
completely [ __ ] separate yeah and
that's a great example of it how the
[ __ ] is it that you go to a concert
everything is sold out and they're just
waiting for that one little snippet and
the rest of the time they don't know who
the [ __ ] you are yeah how that's [ __ ]
trippy yeah and it's terrifying yeah
that's actually terrifying I think I cry
on stage yeah it's like you put all your
heart your soul and your effort into
this thing which is dope like you blew
up on Tick Tock which is good that means
people like whatever that you had yeah
and then they just don't care about any
of your art though like all that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] go play The Tick Tock song man
damn that's [ __ ] trippy yeah it's
it's actually kind of like the nightmare
scenario that has been like the product
or like the the plot line for sitcoms
and things of that nature about artists
like this we're like this is the plot
line the nightmare plot line for an
artist yeah and it's happening in real
time
holy sh you know I was just talking
about this with a friend of mine where I
feel like we truly live in an episode of
Black Mirror like I love that Series
right yeah and because it's basically
kind of foreshadowing what we what they
believe or the director or the writers
believe it's happening to this world and
it seems a little hyperbolic like very
extreme but now I don't think so like
like when I every time I see something
about Kanye I'm like is this real
like is he for real right now yeah and
then it's not even what he does that
shocks me it's how people respond to it
that shocks me the most so for example
he'll put out a statement and he'll say
listen I love everybody right I even
love the Nazis like Hitler I love Hitler
I'll say it I love Nazis
and then people will dissect that and
they go he's saying that as a Christian
that he loves everybody it's like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] I understand that it's still
inappropriate and then you'll see people
defend that and this is what I'm talking
about stupid people will defend other
stupid people you know what I'm saying
they know that what he's saying is
inappropriate and I'll give somebody a
great example right
let's say I don't know let's say my
mom's a [ __ ] raging [ __ ] everybody
knows in Sacramento she's the biggest
[ __ ] in town right but my mom got shot
and she got killed yesterday would you
come up and be like hey your mom was a
[ __ ] she deserved it no you probably
should give me your condolences right
yeah it's true she was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
inappropriate though
people are forgetting about I wonder if
like because the inner people are
forgetting the social aspect of what it
is to be a [ __ ] human being yeah and
so when they look at somebody like Kanye
when he says these public statements
nobody ever stops and says okay not
nobody but there's a group of people
that don't understand that they go well
what's wrong with him saying that he
loves everybody it's like dude okay
you're [ __ ] ugly what if I just came
up to you and was like dude that face of
yours trash it's true you know what I
mean you look like trash but should I
have said it probably not ugly you know
what I mean yeah but people don't like
to flip these rules on themselves right
these rules only apply to everybody else
but me yeah Mandy when you told me that
[ __ ] music thing that [ __ ] blows my
mind man yeah like that's a a legit
nightmare for me yeah it's it's honestly
something that I've been seeing more and
more lately where there's it's almost
like this also sense of entitlement
that's coming from that audience as well
um I went to another show
where it was a more mildly known artist
that was performing in
it was a lot of club music so there's
all these joints that a lot of the kids
that were there they knew all the music
they knew every song when it started and
there was this very weird thing that
made me feel like taking a year and a
half off really uh lost the etiquette
for a lot of people because they didn't
get to experience a lot of that
and also we're at this point where
people don't really care about what's
happening in real life because so much
cool [ __ ] happened on the internet
that's a good way to put it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um there was this point where at this
show this this artist was performing and
every song at the very start of it the
crowd would get super hyped because they
recognized recognize the Beats of the
song they would wrap along through the
hook and they would party with them and
then the song would end and it would go
dead silent waiting for the next song
then the next song would start and the
exact same thing would happen and it
cycled through the entire 30 minute set
what the [ __ ] do they not even know how
to party anymore bro that this was in it
was so weird for even him that his
nervous tick was after every song and he
realized that would happen he would walk
back and talk to the DJ
oh my god dude there's even no
performance etiquette but he didn't know
what to do
this I was trying to get them hyped he
said Make some noise for yourselves and
nobody made noise bro Jesus Christ man
so the nervous tick happened when like
yo the normal shit's not working right
now none of it and he was still super
kind about the whole set too like he
wasn't rude to the audience or anything
After experiencing that because he's
still getting the hype but then it was
almost like as you get to the end of the
song you start dreading that the song's
about to be over oh my god dude I can't
even imagine
yeah dude this is why like sometimes
when I go to like independent artist
[ __ ] like I really [ __ ] with it because
if you're an independent artist that's
pulling in like 300 to 200 people yeah
you know those people [ __ ] with you
heavy yeah and everybody's there to like
have a good time
and that's what I pre you know when I
saw like clips of you know for example
uh was it was it the weekend or was it
Franco who the [ __ ] was it that got a
water bottle phone it it was a kid Cuddy
at rolling loud bro that should piss me
off so bad that [ __ ] actually made my
blood boil man like Kid Cudi deserves
respect and then they would have the
audacity to throw water bottles at him
as he's performing yeah and they get mad
at him for walking off stage like there
have been a couple of really bad moments
like that too like where uh there was
the year at camp flogna that the fans
had started a rumor that Frank Ocean was
going to be the special guest but the
special guest was Drake and they boot
him off stage
of what
are you insane
that's [ __ ] crazy to me that's why I
wonder too is like how do people consume
content now like
you know when you know when we were
growing up like remember when we would
get music right
before anybody did a review on an album
they would have to sit through the
[ __ ] album yeah you would sit through
it from track to track to track and
listen to the whole compilation because
every album has a [ __ ] story it's
never just a single everything builds up
to it you have to listen from track one
all the way through 12 13 14. now people
will just pick a song out they'll listen
to it halfway that's [ __ ] fire move
on to the next one yeah it's like damn
man like the way people consume your
content now it's so quick and it's very
defeating for an artist like I think
that's why a lot of people moved away
from the model of making albums they
just do singles now they're not gonna
even listen to the whole [ __ ] album
well even like it at the time when like
the blogs and stuff were doing all this
too right they were that was where a big
shift started to happen even in the way
that the sources and resources were
listening to music because instead of
giving it time and having a really well
thought out and well-listened review to
an album every blog started doing the
first listen review so that they could
have the first post about the album up
yo that's big facts and then that
gradually shifted even further into just
the way that it's consumed now where
it's like I remember I was talking to
John Hart a while ago so this was like
this is the cool thing that I got out of
working in radio was that when I got to
sit with artists I got to approach that
from the artist standpoint and I
remember sitting with John Hart Who did
Who Booty that was his big single with
he had the imsu version he had a French
Montana version that all did big numbers
and when he came back to making music he
had a single that was kind of bubbling a
little bit and this is years later and
he said bro I felt like I came out to a
completely different world because when
we dropped Who Booty we were working
that song for a year to a year and a
half and now when you drop a single you
got to have the next one in two weeks
yeah or you got to be pushing two
singles at the same time yeah to see it
work and so is the attention span has
shifted so much this is this is like
kind of why I uh for me too as somebody
who was creating so much like YouTube
content and why it's hard for me now
it's like
I
I think I'm very fortunate because I
started YouTube a lot earlier so my fan
base now who [ __ ] they [ __ ] with me
very heavy yeah right so what I put out
what I do they support 100 and they wait
for but that's because I started in a
different era now it's like you'll put
out a video for two weeks or you won't
put out a two they'll forget you like
that
and with these like quick content
creators
they always have to apologize I'm sorry
I didn't put out content I'm sorry I
didn't put out content it's like do you
understand that when you're a YouTuber
and you're putting out five [ __ ]
videos a week and you miss one it's like
you're doing a TV show that doesn't have
like a weekly run time it's [ __ ]
every day and then that's what you have
to run on and then you have to do
Instagram you have to create separate
content for Instagram and be
entertaining on that oh by the way do
Tick Tock hey be funny on Twitter as
well right yeah and then go back to
YouTube and do it all over again and you
have to oh then you know what hey do
twitch like [ __ ] man yeah bro you're
always on and for me I got overwhelmed
with this type of [ __ ] like I got
overwhelmed with like trying to create
content for so many different Avenues
because people will forget you the next
day yeah it's kind of unreal and I saw
it on Instagram too where it's like I
wouldn't post for like
two weeks right and Instagram too wasn't
a Content place for me it was literally
a landing page for people who could see
stuff outside of the content I was
creating but now because Instagram is
obviously owned by Facebook it's all
about monetization if you don't do
things that are mod like that are able
to be monetized it's not even visible
anymore Instagram used to be about
pictures yeah [ __ ] pictures now it has
to be reels yeah I can't even post
nobody will see the photos if I post a
photo yeah but they will see that real
though which is [ __ ] nuts and I think
like now that the landing page of
Instagram has become this app where it's
not hey what's what's Brandon up to
what's Sushi up to
ah I don't care he's not posting content
like you have to be extra now you have
to show out yeah how many channels have
we seen of somebody just walking around
with the [ __ ] money hey what would
you do if you wanted if if I told you
suck my dick
hey hey what would you hey when did you
lose your virginity oh I can't believe
he asked her if he lost his virginity
like [ __ ] out of here you dumb [ __ ]
like dude your content [ __ ] is ass
right and you'll see this [ __ ] too
they'll create this content and every
new content creator that I've seen and
everybody knows this too you blow up for
about a year or two and then you
disappear
what happens you get burnt out because
you're creating content not even for
yourself you're creating it for for
likes and Views and that [ __ ] eats away
at you every yeah day yeah I know
content creators who like literally look
at their phone and they go oh [ __ ] I
lost like 10 screws oh [ __ ] what do I do
to get them back like bro what about
what you create what about the longevity
and I could say this I've been on the
space now for 10 plus years and I still
make a living off of this [ __ ] yeah
a lot of people don't last that long
I've seen people go through psychosis
breaks I've seen people like end up in
like psych wards which is so crazy and
they go like I have no friends it's like
that's your fault bro you did everything
you could to build
a business off of what everybody said
about you but you never cared about what
you created right so what was the
longevity in that yeah people's opinions
about you change every [ __ ] day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
ain't nobody know
S I was feeling low
hey but I'm up right now hey
I took the heart away trying to be
number one but now I'm feeling like the
man again like all my [ __ ] fresher
than I get a clue man I can't listen to
the fans and then became my own man
again figured it was time for me to
revisit the plan since the labels try to
use me girls try to seduce me and all of
these producers I'll try to over produce
me I sounded better when all of my
losers fruity around the same time that
Rudy was still calling himself Rufio
causes for Studios really no groupie
hoes but still had the ratchets and
go-go dancers at Sushi shows letting the
booty show that everyone is who she know
but swear up and down on their lives
they wasn't groupies though okay
whatever you say the same bottle rats
are in for Rose a new say but I digress
before I start a quarter Lupe I really
just want my golden age to make it to
the new way that 2009 when everything
was grind hella cruising my shitty were
on the verge of getting shot maybe it
wasn't time but it still remains on my
mind it's about time my city climbs or
something other than a crime rate and
lead them on state they're just a shine
you gotta
[Music]
without the cruiser can't be grounded
you would never know me if it was on my
own accord I would have kept it low-key
and I would have never had that drive
till I accepted those keys but since we
planted those seeds just take a look at
what we be on I'm on the radio Prime
Time like I'm Dion buzzing to Infinity
but I feel it like I'm beyond I'm light
years ahead of what we on
I think that was where I for me that a
lot of that break from the craft of
creating for myself
became more important again more
recently because I spent so much time
and I actually got a speech from one of
my closest friends and now roommate he
was like bro everything that you've done
in the past that has made big waves has
always been an accessory to somebody
else like you've been doing this to Aid
the radio station you've been doing this
to put on for this person you've been
doing this to expand somebody else's
brand but when you put that effort into
yours that is when you're gonna see all
of these all the fruits of your labor
because right now you are
taking what you think everybody wants of
you but not doing anything that's
creative for you and when you give
yourself to people that's when they'll
become a part of your tribe and of your
community and you don't have to worry
about any of that or any of that burnout
because you're not burning yourself out
you're feeding yourself and people are
now consuming that well here's the thing
too like I know what that feels like
because I I I had a moment too where so
years ago I was a part of this channel
called just kidding news right and we
were we were killing on that [ __ ] like
we were stacking money like it was crazy
dude it was it was a fun ride what I
found out and the reason why I stopped
doing that was because and you'll see a
lot of people do this too when they work
for bigger companies
it's very easy to be a boss and say
things very like poignantly and be very
confident when you're [ __ ] around
with somebody else's money yeah you know
because you could place the blame and
you could place all this personal
responsibility onto something else so
for me when I was a part of just kidding
news I got very comfortable because the
paycheck was coming in I came in I did
my funny part the bosses of Barton Joe
they would run their [ __ ] and I did that
thing for damn near like [ __ ] eight
years I started getting too comfortable
with relying My Success making myself as
part of somebody else's instead of just
being like okay let me just bet on
myself and it was scary because that
paycheck was gone now and I was like
well now you gotta [ __ ] work and then
what I did that's when I booked this
Netflix show that's when I booked this
like short film I started doing other
big things because I took a chance on
myself yeah I started putting that same
amount of effort that I did into
somebody else's company and somebody
else's work and I put it back here and
it worked but it's such a scary [ __ ]
thing because now you're personally
responsible for whether you sink or
whether you float yeah and that is
frightening man because you're going to
find out if you're full of [ __ ] or not
yeah for sure bro there are those
moments where like you have to really
bet on your own accountability and
without anybody like every once in a
while there's gonna be that empty space
where everybody around you is busy and
they're not going to be there to hold
you accountable for what you're doing
even if they support what you're doing
so you have to be able to push that
forward and I've realized that very I
realized it very quickly as a lot of the
lockdown was happening and we were all
as far as like DJs and and artists were
making our transition to doing live
streaming stuff I was finding all the
ways I could to allow myself to be
creative in that format and be as
consistent as possible in that format
with the amount of free time that I
ridiculously had at the time yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and because of
that I started seeing the fruits of that
labor show and it also made me realize
how much hard work goes into building my
my own craft and how much I care about
it I saw how much I cared by how much
time I was spending in really mastering
some of those things so when I got on
Twitch it was right as I had lost my job
in radio the lockdown started
and I transitioned everything into doing
a twitch radio show how do you lose your
job in radio it was a big budget cut
that happened all over the entire
Corporation and they cut time slots so
anybody who was doing a night show at
the time gone
oh [ __ ] and I was the night show guy
damn yeah that's trippy man like how
does that is that transition kind of
scary for you it was very scary yeah but
it wasn't the first time the first time
though it was at hot 103.5
and there was a big budget cut
after one of the other companies had
actually filed for bankruptcy this our
Corporation got scared and made budget
cuts all over the corporation and they
dropped everybody in the morning shows
and everybody in the night shows at the
same time and all of our mix show DJs
damn that week though
the opposing radio station saw it as an
opportunity to Rebrand so they blew out
their entire staff and started calling
new people and they found out I was free
and they called me oh [ __ ] but this time
when it happened at that station after
falling I guess Falling Up
when this one happened it was a lot
scarier because there wasn't another
opposing place for me to go that saw
what I was doing this meant that it was
time for me to start grinding it out on
my own yeah and so
I transitioned that into we always had
this dream when we were working at hot
103.5 that we would be able to do a show
where we filmed it and had our whole day
turn into a basically like a reality
show around the radio station yeah yeah
yeah and I was like bro there's a format
that we can do this in now because
everybody's learning how to use OBS and
do the whole twitch thing and live
stream it out and I started figuring out
how to set up multiple cameras in my
apartment I had angles going in Every
Which Way in this loft apartment in Sac
that looked really dope and so I was
like dude I can do my full radio show
that I was just doing but now have all
the cameras on it that we always dreamed
of I learned how to have Discord patched
into my DJ controller so I could take
phone calls and I would like have people
call in and do segments and things like
that and so it was like all right now
let's see how much further I can take
this so I started learning how to do
more graphic design stuff so that I
could design the way the entire stream
looked from top to bottom doing ads I
did like commercials for everybody and I
would shoot them out to all my other
streamer friends and have them show the
commercial during their Stream So they
knew when mine was that's dope I was
figuring out ways to take everything I
learned from radio and I'll step it up a
notch because I'm basically building a
resume at this point damn that's amazing
are you still streaming right now I have
taken a break from it because I was
working on all this stuff with mstr
which is the watch company I've been
working with for a bit right here now
let's go right and my man [ __ ]
[ __ ] got me right right here let's go
let's go man
um but the plan is to be back on a
regular schedule with that because we
um are having a transition in our house
as well in our apartment where
somebody's moving out we're having a new
roommate come in who does film and video
and things like that as well and has
also been getting into streaming
um and the last iteration of the show I
actually had Rudy on as a special guest
and he brought Duckworth with him oh
[ __ ] that's dope because they have their
single favorite out and we did an
interview in my living room and they
also performed a couple of songs live
from the living room that's [ __ ]
amazing and so it created this whole new
energy in the space that was like all
right we can keep leveling up from here
because now I'm doing this in a space
that for one is my own it feels
comfortable to be here and at the same
time it gives me the freedom and the
challenge of creating something from the
ground up that nobody there's no FCC
behind it the only rules are whatever
like terms of service are like no nudity
and stuff on Twitch and things like that
but it was allowing me to really get
creative in that space I think like the
dope thing about like being in control
your space and we were talking about
this off camera it's like you know no
matter how many products that I've been
in you know things that I'm auditioning
for or whatever I always go back to like
YouTube because I'll tell you this right
now out of all the spaces that's been
available no matter how much drama that
YouTube has gone like with the ad
AdSense issues or whatever yeah I [ __ ]
with YouTube the most out of every
platform it really allowed for the
Independent Artists to kind of like
create their own way yeah right and I
don't really like what a lot of the
content I see on YouTube now but still
at the same time like when you start
going into a lot of like industry
industry stuff you are literally at the
beck and call of bigger people out there
who control your dollar 24 7. we were
talking about that kid La Russell he
controls his dollar and then on top of
that he allows people to invest in him
and invest into his company how smart is
that [ __ ] yeah man when you become that
artist like and you really [ __ ] with
your own vision and you believe in
yourself there's really nothing that can
stop you because it's just a matter of
time right yeah when you develop that
product you develop that art and like
for me too like I've been going through
this whole like imposters and everything
where I feel like everything that I've
worked for I don't deserve so I you know
will so I'll self-sabotage a little bit
right like I'll see an opportunity and I
convince myself I don't want that [ __ ]
yeah it's not me but it's just like I
know it's because I feel like I don't
deserve it then I'll I feel better
having somebody else take it because I
don't deserve it so I don't want it
anymore the great thing about this space
is that there's no red tape here if I
have an idea that I want to shoot I
could just [ __ ] do it it just takes
time yeah you know just takes my
personal time yeah there's I mean
generally once you have the equipment
that that your overheads already paid
for once you start making money I even
think about like even you mentioned like
there's there's a lot of content that
you don't like that's on YouTube but
like the fact that it's free and
available for somebody to put that
content out is important yeah because it
allows for what you do here and for what
we can produce here on our own you know
free time and with our own free
creativity that's it's important that
some of the stuff that we don't like
exists a hundred percent unfortunately
I mean that's the cool thing about
YouTube man like it was really it was
kind of like for I think for people who
want to be like in television to act and
stuff like that yeah it was kind of what
like uh SoundCloud did for the
independent artist yeah it's what
Myspace did for the appended music
artist and that's what YouTube did for
somebody like me who wanted to do like
TV and comedy but
um you know there was a lot of people
that weren't really knocking on my door
because they didn't believe in me you
know that's the main reason why I did my
own film with my buddy Justin is because
these agencies I will forever remember
these agencies like I'm not going to say
their [ __ ] names but they
I I wanted to uh an act and they're like
oh we'll sign you to our digital media I
was like I didn't say I want to be a
part of your digital media I have
digital media I want to go audition and
they're like we don't need you for that
cool did this film next thing you know
those same agencies came back and
they're like hey who are you I was like
I just had a meeting with you six months
ago and you told me I wasn't good enough
you know I know it's messed up about
that that's exactly how I met Rudy
this is this is like Myspace era right
yeah this is at the time where hypey
movement is making this big wave and I'm
making hyphy music at the time and Rue
at the time is producing for
Sacramento's biggest Hive yard is
blabstar and he has a couple of these
joints out so I messaged him on MySpace
I was like hey I don't remember the
terminology it was probably an up and
down case letters yeah yeah it was
probably terrible to in retrospect but I
remember I had sent in this message
asking him if we could work together
um because I really liked his music it
was dope seeing another Asian in the
space as well especially because it was
so not open for that at the time it
seemed like there was no diversity
within the space at the time and so I
asked him if he would be down to work
and he left me on red for hell along
yeah yeah and then I dropped a remix of
A Tribe Called Quest song it was find a
way by A Tribe Called Quest and I did
this random recut of it and it starts
Making Waves and I get this message from
Rue and it literally just says yeah we
could work and this is like a year later
it's [ __ ] funny here's the worst part
bro so he sends me a beat and me and
Chewie get on this beat and Chewie was
an artist that still does still makes a
lot of waves on the Underground now yo
chewy that's so [ __ ] funny man like I
you know what's hilarious about that
[ __ ] I mean just a real quick sidebar
it's like I've been talking about
chewing other people for [ __ ] years
man yeah man and uh I remember this one
[ __ ] like Freestyle [ __ ] that he did
it was you know that Park that
neighborhood with the lake in Sacramento
yeah Elk Grove and he was just [ __ ]
doing his [ __ ] and that's the [ __ ] I
should send to people I'm like watch
this kid's gonna be the next one yeah
he's so [ __ ] good morning by two
post-mortem that's what it was I was
like this and at the time how old was he
he was like 16 or 15 years old no he
would we were definitely like at we were
probably like 19 okay 19. you're still a
teenager yeah and he was still young for
sure [ __ ] dude what what kind of [ __ ]
Talent is this [ __ ] you know yeah so
that's so crazy that you mentioned about
yeah we used to call that spot Heaven
yeah
um but yeah so we had gotten on this
song and
um
finally Rue wanted to work now
and we got this joint out had our homie
DJ John do cuts on it we put it out it
was a band camp release so it was just
like straight to Consumer kind of
dropped it didn't really do numbers like
that but Rue was excited about hearing
like a real hip-hop record on one of his
joints so he asked me if I wanted to
work on some more stuff and he invited
me over to his crib
so more dating myself
I hopped on MapQuest and I put his
address in
why does this man live three minutes
away from my house bro that's [ __ ]
funny dude I rode my scooter to his
house that day that's hilarious yeah we
started working on music and I've been
friends ever since that's [ __ ] funny
you know what's so trippy about that too
like you know I have an interesting it's
a little different from yours but
there's this kid who uh he's a you know
he does like online comedy or whatever
whatnot
and I guess like he kind of like blew up
in his own way right and I met this kid
uh he did a show with me and I didn't
know who the [ __ ] he was right and he
was like Hey I just want to let you know
that uh like I really looked up to you I
was like looked up you know past tense I
was like all right cool that's that's
fine right whatever whatnot right so I'm
performing stand it was terrible and
then I don't know who this kid is he
goes like like I messaged you years ago
and I wanted to collab with you but you
kind of like you didn't even open it up
and I'm like
I don't read my DMs yeah and I was like
he goes yeah and at the time you know
what the funny thing is I didn't know
about that 99 plus thing on the side so
there was just a bunch of messages from
people
years my buddy Tim told me about that
[ __ ] because of uh [ __ ] T-Pain and I
was like T-Pain was making talking about
that [ __ ] about him like all these like
artists hitting him up I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about what is that
and then I didn't know that [ __ ] and
then literally all these [ __ ] people
were hitting me up yo let's collab let's
collab let's collab and I'm talking
about three four years and I'll be like
yeah why not
you know and I had no [ __ ] clue but
this kid he had like a chip on his
shoulder and he was like yeah I really
wanted to collab with you and you didn't
even like you know bought I was like
number one I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about I never received
them but I did it was just in the 99
plus I used to know about it at the time
because at that point nobody explained
it to me yeah I was like second of all I
was like even if I did know who you are
I saw you do stand up you just bombed
you suck
foreign
went dead silent he was like oh oh I was
like so you've seen all my videos you
don't think that I would say something
back to you I was like bro you suck you
[ __ ] suck I was like you're an
Instagram [ __ ] comedian bro you keep
your jokes online like get that chip off
your shoulder I was like your success is
your success and whatever you did you
worked hard to get at it right I was
like now you're over here trying to say
like oh you know I got you I don't know
who you are and I still don't know who
you [ __ ] are I would still not pick
you out in a [ __ ] crowd dude you make
these [ __ ] goofy little [ __ ]
little Asian jokes on your [ __ ] cool I
don't give a [ __ ] people like your stuff
you know work to your crowd yeah don't
don't have this chip on your shoulder
about me like you know doing what I'm
doing I don't even know you [ __ ] DM
me and then I you know when he told me I
finally found it it was like [ __ ]
like four years ago and this kid he was
like a little kid at the time so he was
like when he did this he was like 19 so
he was like 15. I said bro you know I'm
30.
what were we gonna do you're 14 you're
16 years
it
even if you were popping what the [ __ ]
would I talk about with a 14 year old
you dumbass you just [ __ ] grew pubes
like the [ __ ] is this kid talking about
like I was just like the weirdest thing
like this level of [ __ ] entitlement
like listen anybody who has like remote
talent that hits me up I follow them
back immediately because I just want to
see what they do even if it has nothing
to do with me right there's this kid who
plays like a viola
I don't know who the [ __ ] he is but he's
a fan of mine and then he commented I
saw like a little check mark thing I saw
stuff he [ __ ] plays that I don't I've
never known anybody to play a viola
before but he's [ __ ] sick and I was
like blip follow right we're never
probably gonna do anything together we
have no reason to yeah but I just like
watching talented people [ __ ] do
their [ __ ] it inspires me yeah right it
doesn't matter what whether it's cooking
whether it's [ __ ] daily vlogging
creating fun content music whatever I
just like being inspired by people who
create art
[Applause]
tell me what you want
tell me what you need
tell me what you want I got a lot of
that
tell me what you want
um
[Music]
don't just tell a hater they could fall
back everything they talking is a cap
and I've been off that blood I ain't
gotta tell them holla back you know who
to call they already know I'm all of
that I got what you want
you need
and it just makes me want to work harder
you know yeah that's the kind of thing
that also kind of like brings me back to
the way and what we consume right
because it's when when you have
something like that that makes you and
kind of like gets you inspired to do
things that's the way that we consume
things because that's the way I consume
things as well it's a lot of just like I
love going down my algorithm and seeing
great graphic design that I can get
inspired from or seeing a eight-year-old
Japanese kid that DJs way better than
all of my friends like all of that stuff
Riles me up and that's the way that I
consume things I like being inspired by
that there's a group chat that I'm in
where there's a couple of people who
always for some reason just like like
sending the lane links to stuff that
just make you mad and you know that you
know that they intentionally make
themselves mad with the content they
consume now like well that's why you're
like that bro because you'd consume
content that makes you mad and so
it's there's a lot of people I call it
trauma porn yeah like they love that
[ __ ] like whenever like something pops
off on it did you see this [ __ ] it's
like no I didn't see it I absolutely
didn't [ __ ] see it because it's the
same [ __ ] over and over again yeah go
back to the Kanye thing I saw him do one
crazy thing I'm done yeah I don't need
to go go ahead and dip back into that
[ __ ] well yeah because it eats away
at me you know that's why a lot of
people say like when you now like when
you get to a certain point you just post
a new ghost now
do things for yourself post and then
ghost and let the people have it yeah
there are [ __ ] like Reddit threads
about how trashy of a human being I am
right there are people who are
threatening to kill me every [ __ ] day
if I went back to read those Reddit
posts which I have like a few years back
hilarious by the way [ __ ] hate
me dude and I'm and I'm always wondering
like that's like the guy who sends the
stuff in the thread to talk about things
that they hate about it's like
I can't even remember the stuff that
they said now but it would be like some
[ __ ] where I remember there's like a
specific person there that would post
every day and I'm like what did I do to
this person every day it's like damn do
you work do you have friends do you get
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is going on in
your life there's so many bigger things
in life than for you to go on Reddit to
talk about this thing that I did today
and it would be like I would tweet
something and then immediately look with
this [ __ ] fat Korean [ __ ] did this
piece of [ __ ] he thinks he's so much
better than people and then people would
try and Below bro daily daily and I'm
like [ __ ] cracking up I'm like damn
what did I do what did I do like dude
you need a hug bro bro for real that's
crazy duck every day every second and
follows me on all my [ __ ]
like damn that's a fan yeah you know in
the worst way possible but in my mind
I'm thinking like damn do you need like
therapy yeah like you got to understand
like that hate that you consume becomes
a part of you every [ __ ] day yeah I
want that's why even on my Twitter [ __ ]
I always block negative [ __ ] now like
the only thing I go on for Twitter is to
see [ __ ] Hawaiian people street fight
that's it I just want to see I want to
see people in Hawaii scrap that's it and
I just want to say is that like a
specific thing that you're getting it's
called 808 scraps
it's my [ __ ] is that why you were out
there
I'm in Hawaii looking for people to
fight like not for me I just want to see
it happen I'll tell you this story like
when I was in Hawaii this is like my
first time in Hawaii I went to a bar
and I didn't understand what people
meant when they said like people in
Hawaii are different right I think
Islanders are just [ __ ] different
they just built different and so I was
at a bar and I see this dude and this
dude comes up and he goes to this other
guy I don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening he just goes
what's up bro you got beef brother and
I'm like
what's going on I was like oh they
should they [ __ ] exchanging meat like
the [ __ ] is going on you're like yeah
you want beef brother we take beef
outside brother I'm like yo I think
these fools are gonna scrap and I'm like
oh somebody's gonna break this up he
goes guy [ __ ] down this beer goes
outside and I'm talking about these two
big ass Island dudes like one if that if
that will suck me I would be waking up
in another Universe dude these fools
start throwing Haymakers guy cracks one
of them guy knocks the dude out floors
him and I'm sitting here just shocked
I'm clutching my purse at this point I'm
like nobody's stopping this this is
insane you know I'm like shock knocks
the dude out the guy picks him up the
guy's bleeding from his [ __ ] mouth
takes him to the bar he goes we good
he's going to squash this he goes cool
we good they get a beer they drink
together the cheers and that's it I'm
like damn people in Hawaii are different
though that is that's that's real that's
real grown man energy though except an
ancient warrior type of [ __ ] they're
like listen I [ __ ] you up we got
nothing else to talk about you want to
squash this or we could [ __ ] run it
back yeah and they squashed they moved
on and then people just went back like
it was nothing they weren't even talking
about it like I was like you know kind
of hearing like yo are they gonna start
talking some [ __ ] and the guy just buys
them a beer they go back so you squash
it good hey so what you gonna get it
tomorrow
you just back that guy's teeth out like
what the [ __ ] is going on but people in
Hawaii they scrapped and everybody
apparently does MMA now so you don't
know what's going to happen back in the
day like I remember like when I was
scrapped with people it was just I wish
there was like camcorders so I could
laugh at myself because I bet you I was
just like wrist curled back you know
screaming just [ __ ] you know thought
I was sick with it but I wasn't really
good
but now like everybody takes like
martial arts so you see people just [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's scary out here man Bro
Dog it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll never want to
fight anymore like I'm so scared of that
[ __ ] like I box and [ __ ] now but that's
within a controlled setting like once it
goes out to the streets I will I'm not
fighting like it's just not happening
there's so many different variables
people can stab you like I have [ __ ] to
lose now now like when things like
escalate that's why I don't like going
out to [ __ ] clubs anymore because
[ __ ] always escalates for no [ __ ]
reason yeah it's scary and you a DJ bro
yeah trust me bro there have been
moments where I'm like damn should I
just go back to doing weddings all the
time or what bro
dog man like even so I was in Sacramento
and I didn't realize like how bad like
the the homeless situation got out there
yeah it got pretty pretty wild because
they all all they did was push them out
of where they were before which was out
by the river and now they're just in the
city everywhere every [ __ ] where like
even in like the nice suburbs yeah and
so like I was I wasn't town because
Sacramento got some fire ass [ __ ]
coffee and so I was getting some coffee
and I just walked by and this two walks
up to me he goes you ain't the one [ __ ]
and I'm like excuse me he goes yeah it's
not you you ain't the [ __ ] one
and I I just I couldn't process what was
going on I'm like me they're like yeah
you're not the one it's like what am I
Jet Li [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about he goes you ain't the one
[ __ ] it's not you and I just I was like
okay I just walked away I feel like if I
was younger I probably would have mouth
off but now I'm thinking this guy might
be crazy yeah he might stab me he might
take something from me dude I I'm not
about any of that type of [ __ ] I'm
always the person that's just gonna be
like okay I'm I'm done with this like
we're not doing this anymore yeah like I
remember like being in K-Town and like
L.A K Town like I'm not I'm sure it's a
lot nicer now
10 years ago not so much like it was it
was always going down it's like an
Entertainment District now yeah it's
it's different dude yeah I've never seen
so many white people there in my life
I'm like holy [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here they're all in their
Boba hunting yeah they're looking for a
[ __ ] Korean [ __ ] dude
and good luck the Ukraine women are
[ __ ] [ __ ] shout out to my wife
yo I told you before we turn this on if
there's anybody who is going to cancel
you it's going to be her bro she's she's
I love
stupid
and I said
now she's great man like um
it's weird because uh you get to like
this point like in a relationship where
I I never felt this way until like
recently where she would be gone for a
week and I'm like
I kind of missed this [ __ ] dude
like what's she doing because I was so
independent doing my own thing yeah
right like even when we were dating and
we were together I never missed her like
that because I was so focused on doing
what I was doing once we became married
we really became a unit like this is I
mean we were a unit before but something
about like that marriage part made me
feel like she was like I was the left
leg and she's the right so now like the
way that I worry about her is so
different and the way that I talk to her
is different now too like for example
like it's when she doesn't take care of
herself I think about like us as a
family unit now now it's not like oh
she'll get better it's like no like
we're a family like you need to worry
about your health because now I'm
concerned about you in our future so
like the way our relationship has
evolved over this past year uh past few
years has been crazy like we've talked
about the podcast where even like
pandemic was the thing that almost broke
us up because I wasn't used to like you
know seeing her every day 24 [ __ ]
seven yeah you know so all those little
things that annoyed you now I had to be
with it all day it's like oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] hate you yeah and same thing
with her back to me she hated me and she
didn't even know she didn't even know
that she did it's interesting because I
feel like I saw a homie of mine actually
um Jamesy he used to go about James
Cavern he now goes by Jamesy who is my
roommate that's actually going to be
moving to Kentucky damn near like next
week oh [ __ ]
um he uh he wrote a song specifically
about that because that experience was
so relevant for so many people and for
him it wasn't even a relationship thing
it was the just him being stuck in a
space even just with roommates at a
certain point where that friendship or
relationship because you see them all
day every day
there's something about like damn that
one thing that I already didn't like is
now like a part of my everyday life
tenfold dog I I would have thoughts and
I would be like I would wake up and I'm
like I gotta look at this [ __ ] face
every day like God damn it she'd just be
sleeping I'm just scowling at her like
look at this [ __ ] snoring ass
[ __ ] just sleeping disgusting
like I and I couldn't escape her like it
was impossible and then you know and I
started thinking about my parents
because they run a business together was
just them too and they see each other's
face every [ __ ] day and now we
understand why they fought so much they
had nowhere to go they had to deal with
this annoying ass [ __ ] person across
from them every [ __ ] day yeah and my
mom was like don't ever do that she goes
like have two separate lives come
together and that's why we had like I
have this [ __ ] man cave I have this
area for me to be who I am I don't have
to bother her she gets to do her stuff
and then we come together and we share
our moments together and it's been so
much better that way yeah and um I think
a lot of people too
because most of my friends aren't like
that they do everything together with
their partner if you go out she goes out
if she goes out you go out and so
there's there's no autonomy at all uh
she and I are very different like
Thanksgiving she wasn't with me she was
out in [ __ ] Europe in Amsterdam
because she wanted to go on a trip yeah
like and I wasn't like but what about me
I'm like no you go enjoy I'm gonna go to
Sacramento I'm gonna go see my friends
have a wedding I'm gonna go to you don't
have to come to the wedding with me just
enjoy yourself yeah and I I prefer that
because I like her having her
independence because once we decide to
have a kid our all of our thoughts and
everything goes into this child right so
while we have this autonomy I want her
to like really just kind of soak in her
independence a lot yeah because it's not
like when you have a kid it gets taken
away it's just a different chapter you
know and
um for her and me like our our identity
is very [ __ ] important because I
don't want to just lose it one day like
where I'm trying to scramble like who Am
I who am I what am I that [ __ ] scares me
man because it takes years for us to
find you know as a musician how hard is
it to find your own voice yeah
by your own style dude even working in
radio it took so long for me to actually
like really dive into like what is my
identity as a personality on this radio
station how do I make sure that that's
something that I hold near and dear to
me and it represents me every time I hop
on the airwaves that same thing it's
like you really have to work on that for
so long so I can definitely feel how
that can be a really important piece to
that even just how did you like
end up like finding it because you know
I you know before we came on like I
started going through the Rolodex of
your music that you put out in the more
recent years because remember last time
I heard your music was years ago it was
different and your your style your sound
everything has evolved right not so much
change like it's evolved I think it's
better so how did you like get to that
point there was a lot of I mean a lot of
it came from during that radio era I did
something that was kind of detrimental
but it also allowed me to experiment
with a lot but I was going to shows all
the time and I was seeing different
artists perform all the time and I kept
going to these shows seeing these
artists perform and going home like I
could do that
and or like seeing the audience that
came out to that show and think to
myself that's the audience that I want
so I can do that to get that and I was
testing out all these different things
for so long and found out how many of
those things weren't for me throughout
that process like trying to make music
like I am Sue and the HBK gang and saves
the Gemini and all them that's not for
me doing like a lot of like the trappier
stuff that you would hear during that
era where ASAP Mob was really kind of
building up and Rocky and Ferg were in
their earlier stages of really getting
popping I tried it didn't work for me
and so I really kind of stepped back
into like I was really a part of this
backpack hip-hop scene and at the same
time the way that I know how to present
that
comes from my knowledge of how to read
an audience it also comes from knowing
how to express myself a lot more now and
allowing myself to really
spew out the emotions rather than just
trying to go for the sonics and I think
that was an issue for a long time as I
was always going for the sound of it and
never for the message behind what I was
talking about and so when I really got
to dive into it and
uh learn how to express that through my
words and still be kind of cool about it
it was that was where I really locked
into it but it took a long time for me
to really feel that out that's really
[ __ ] hard though yeah
you know I think like when you kind of
start off in a position where you know
you identify as just like musicians
musician right because there's like
people who are like the rappers rapper a
lot of people don't know them but every
rapper will say that's their favorite
[ __ ] rapper yeah right and that
became the position of like who Kendrick
was right Kendrick you know obviously he
had he has his radio hits right but you
know you have people like somebody like
someone an artist that I've found
through that [ __ ] Netflix show where
they were doing that competition with ti
yeah D smoke like I listened to him and
I'm like he has that great balance of
something that's very conscious very
lyrical but it's a it's a banger
everything's a [ __ ] Banger yeah and
that is like that really [ __ ] hard
pocket to find yeah you know um and I
think a lot of artists kind of go
through that but it's interesting that
when you talk about music how like I'll
because you know for me like music is
always a hobby I've never really been
like a hundred percent into it right it
was just something I always did for fun
also because I couldn't talk to women so
it was the only it's the only thing I
could do is the only way I don't see
titties
and so you know
like I was explaining to some of these
kids who wanted to do music right and
you know you were talking about people
who would perform there's a lot of
people who go into the the genre of
being a vocalist and a musician well
guess what there's some there's things
like auto-tune melodyne and the way that
you process these vocals you anybody can
sound good nowadays yeah as long as you
have the right like typical like a
decent tone you can make you can shift
[ __ ] or you don't even really need a
decent tone anymore bro it's kind of
trippy right yeah and then I'll see some
of these artists I'm not gonna say their
names I'll see them live and I'm like
holy [ __ ] you can't sing yeah I'm like
what the [ __ ] did I just witnessed and
it was the worst show I've ever been to
I remember there were plenty of shows
where
we were actually starting to get scared
to go to certain people's shows because
we're like
bro I I know for a fact that when they
performed that song Live they're not
gonna sing it they're gonna wrap it yeah
100 terrified going to a show knowing
that the magic was gonna be spoiled and
that [ __ ] would kill me man because like
you hear it you hear this like refined
product and that's why you hear like
people who are really good Studio
artists but performance is a such a
different thing man like it is a
performance yeah from A to Z you gotta
have everything [ __ ] right man yeah
and a lot of the times like they're like
oh this song is good in studio but I
could have taken your voice and
anybody's voice that made that [ __ ] dope
yeah it wasn't you it was the engineer
that made you [ __ ] dope yeah and they
had to perform that live and I'm like
dude this show is such trash like the
performance is bad the confidence isn't
even there they're not used to being on
stage yeah and I think like that that
kind of killed like concerts for me a
little bit where I I didn't want to see
I wanted to still enjoy the music
because I would walk away from this and
I didn't want to listen to music anymore
yeah and most people like are [ __ ]
Fizz the [ __ ] out so they don't know
what's going on but I'm there for the
music yeah so because I don't do drugs
like that and I'm like oh [ __ ] like
y'all understand how bad this is this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] terrible I I've had like
the opposite experience where I saw
somebody live first and then the
recording was really bad oh no and but
like the live performance was great oh
[ __ ] but the but and that was how I got
introduced to them and then going back
to listen to the recorded version I'm
like bro what happened
um and so the one really good one that I
had was I had never heard a Chance the
Rapper before and I got booked to MC
like host the show when he was on tour
for Acid Rap which is the project that
pretty much blew him up after 10 days oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah and so Acid
Rap comes out and I have no idea who
this dude is I'm just hosting the show
for one he oversells the venue
so they they ended up releasing extra
tickets that day knowing that they were
risking the fire code and they sold it
out over packed it had the place rocking
and the crowd is so dope that they're
[ __ ] with every opener too which I
have never seen I love this point
especially in hip-hop it didn't make
sense to me to see that chance goes out
on stage and puts on one of the dopest
performances that I had seen at the time
super young at this point too and I go
back and listen to his music and I was
like bro he matches like that's [ __ ]
dope like I found you at the perfect
time and that's how I became a chance to
rapper fan from that point on it was
like I got to see how you for one
interacted with the crowd I had the rare
situation where I got to also see him
behind the scenes because I was hosting
the show and he was cool with me
backstage and then got to watch him Rock
the crowd find out his music is great
and get to carry that with me I'm a fan
forever now bro that's crazy man like
some people too were you know I'll see
this too where uh some people will I'll
see them first perform and they'll do
like a stripped down performance of
their song and it turned out the strip
down perform is way better way better
bro because I'm like dude the production
on the original track is trash yeah like
it's even the EQ is [ __ ] terrible
it's mixed terrible everything's bad
about it I'm like hey maybe you should
just do like Studio [ __ ] because like
Studio live versions yeah this is this
is not it yeah it would crush me dude
yeah I'm like oh dude you you actually
you need to get a better producer yeah
you need to get a better producer a
better [ __ ] engineer and I think that
too is hard too because that's just
expensive yeah bro I've I've tried like
you know learning how to like engineer
my I can't do this this is literally
learning another language this is
[ __ ] hard like I spent so much money
on [ __ ] apps and [ __ ] I'm like all
right cool I'm about to [ __ ] download
this [ __ ] let's get Ableton boom open it
up what the [ __ ] is this
what is this yo you know what the
biggest the biggest cheat code W that
ever happened was when Fruity Loops was
and it's like oh my God eighth or ninth
phase they introduced a plug-in called
sound goodizer
or you literally just flip the button
really mix the whole thing that's
[ __ ] amazing all right thank you
that was a Trippy thing like I I started
like watching all these tutorials and I
would watch the tutorials and it would
get me even more confused and I'm like
yeah I don't know any of this
terminology that you're [ __ ] using
right now and I don't know how to get to
this [ __ ] so like I would like try to
mix my own vocals and it would be like
six hours and it came out worse I'm like
how does the vocal sound worse like how
what did I do here yeah I did the same
thing you just told me and it didn't
[ __ ] work and then I would send it to
my buddy of mine and then he'll just me
I'm okay well I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening all right and like he just
does it so quick because that's what he
does for a living and I just see him and
it's like somebody just programming uh
some [ __ ] it just everything's
flying super fast yeah they have this
deck thing going on I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah three monitors yeah
all kinds of things going on and I'm
just sitting there with my mouth open
I'm like uh what are you doing bro like
this is so fast and I'm just here click
drag click drag is this right and then
my [ __ ] my [ __ ] my audio setup's
terrible too so when I hear it in the
car I'm like this is trash I I respect
[ __ ] like audio Engineers so much man
yeah bro they could make and break your
[ __ ] record I wanted to do it and I
just didn't have the patience bro
because it's not it's not and it's not
that there's not creativity that goes
into it but I always had I always
enjoyed just like the stacking sounds
and doing all that kind of stuff but
when it came down to doing it's like
doing the math equations that you never
wanted to memorize you have to be a
[ __ ] nerd to do that [ __ ] I'm sorry
man you have to be a [ __ ] like you
could get get into like zeros and ones
or some [ __ ] yeah because it's so
[ __ ] meticulous and like like my
buddy Ray he does like audio engineering
for movies and [ __ ] and I just see what
he does I'm like [ __ ] dweebed
I love that guy I was like he's done all
my sketches and [ __ ] so I'm like look at
this nerds
[ __ ] hella good at his [ __ ] and I
don't know what the hell is going on and
they can hear things that I can't hear
yeah I just know that the end product is
good I just don't know how to get to it
yeah I think like um like studio
recording too that for a lot of people
who just want to get into music it's so
different from them for performing live
and when you were talking about two is
like the emotion behind things like when
like people who can't sing they don't
understand how hard that aspect is it's
like I was explaining to a friend of
mine who he wanted to get into singing
Terrible by the way we already had this
conversation so we're okay
because he asked me like Point Blank
right yeah but I have a lot of these
conversations with friends
um and they talk to me this way too you
know it's just we're buddies you know
and he goes hey I want to try music I
[ __ ] laughed in his face I was like
why right he goes like it's just
something I always want to do and I know
what you guys would think oh you're
crushing his dream I'm not crushing his
[ __ ] dreams all right that's my
friend shut the [ __ ] up I'll say
whatever the [ __ ] I want with my friends
and I was like yeah if you want he goes
like you want to do a track together I
was like listen I'll [ __ ] kill you
don't
you ever disrespect me like that again
doc I know I'm not a musician anymore
but don't disrespect me like that he
goes why I was like dude you're tone
deaf so you know this right you're
[ __ ] tone deaf and he was like am I
it was like Doc you're tone deaf you
don't know this [ __ ]
I've heard you sing in the car with me
for years am I you would see blood come
out my [ __ ] ears I'm like you can't
[ __ ] sing and he goes okay well what
about like you know if you know if an
engineer can come I was like yeah
probably but even then those things have
a limit yeah and you are beyond that
[ __ ] limit
and then uh another friend of our who's
in the circle he was chiming in he was
like well we kind of wanted to do music
together I was like oh you too
right okay you you want to do music too
and I'm not saying this from a point of
like me being snobby I've heard these
[ __ ] sing and I was telling him
I was like
you maybe I was like because you're not
tone deaf I was like you you could
probably learn how to sing and I was
like I've heard you sing like for real
for real and I was like he was like okay
but what can I do differently and this
is the thing that a lot of people don't
understand like when you record on a
[ __ ] mic I was like you sing
everything exactly the same
whether it's the first verse whether
it's the bridge whether it's the chorus
you sing it all the [ __ ] same how you
sing things is very important to how
people feel it right so I was giving him
and I was like I want you to sing
something I don't want to sing I was
like just whatever we're in this room
together just [ __ ] sing whatever song
that you want right and it was um
the [ __ ] is that music Soul Child song
uh girl I know this might seems strange
right so he was doing that and I was
like you sing it and he's saying it for
me I was like here's your problem
you're singing Everything in key but
you're [ __ ] blasting me in the face
with your [ __ ] vocals you know what I
mean yeah people don't know how to like
subdue their voice they don't know how
to control this stuff they don't
understand when to put things in it's
like when people do too many runs yeah
they'll start the sound bro
so I'd be going to jams right and I go
to see these live jams and there's one
that I go to where the rule is no covers
and it's like as soon as they find out
that's the rule they forget what words
are
so it's just a bunch of runs and uah's
the whole time and it's come to the
point where I'm just like damn bro like
maybe this ain't for you
dude this is so yeah I'm gonna tell you
this [ __ ] so
so my boy he used to date this girl
right there's two [ __ ] funny stories
about this so we have a buddy he's a
he's a producer for Rockefeller he legit
and
you ever had like somebody that you
bring around to like a group of friends
that are talented that you regret
bringing them around yes bro trust me
yes
you're like you have zero self-awareness
of this girl
so this guy is a legit producer right
and dope guy and we're sitting around
and she sings right he casually sings
and then out of nowhere he's like oh I
want to come kick it with you guys which
is like all right whatever when we kick
it we don't really talk about music or
our work we're just he's like at the
studio that's what he's doing so we're
going in there drinking whatever
chilling then
out of nowhere this [ __ ] comes out with
a USB drive
soon I'm telling you
this [ __ ] comes out with me she's like
I do music you plug it in talk
I thought it was gonna be like a song
that she worked on it was literally her
just scatting and mumbling on some
[ __ ] where I [ __ ] you [ __ ] not it
was just audio out the left Left Channel
so there's just like everything wrong
with it everything works and then you
see this full of just being so polite
going like this yeah
I'm like well you ain't gotta do all
that you ain't got to do all that man
and then afterwards like my buddy told
me like you took his girl out like what
the [ __ ]
do this to me but the [ __ ] the funny
thing about this is like to her that's
appropriate and she kind of lives in
this delusion like you know what the
[ __ ] you just did it's not like oh we're
not gonna be invited that's our friend
but like have some [ __ ] Common Sense
where the [ __ ] would you do that yeah
I'll even show you later on like there's
a video of her performing
and it's just what you were talking
about she goes up on and she sings like
an eight minute song right and it's like
let me just imitate it for you guys real
quick it literally sounds like a baby
learning how to talk for the first time
eight minutes long bro and then towards
the end of it she goes she goes she
starts running out of things to say and
she goes yeah that was a song that I
just made up I don't even know what I
just said no [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that wasn't a real song it was
eight minutes long listen bro it's okay
to do that at home yes this is this is
how a lot of people write music that's
totally fine that's not the finished
product you know who I think ruined that
Ryan honestly
laughs
he did he really did bro and in the
Myspace era people thought that song
slapped bro I was like he did this song
called gibberish and it's like you don't
understand any of the words and that's
what's beautiful about it I was like bro
extra scratch track bro and he put it
out
you're tripping that's like that's so
I've had that conversation with so many
people and they said that same [ __ ] and
I was trying to explain to them I was
like in the writing process that's how
all these songs sound yeah that's how
all them it's literally a scratch track
right and then afterwards you come back
when you put actual words to it and
they're like this is next level genius
it's is not it is not it was a demo he
didn't sell bro and you don't perform
that and they're like yo how come nobody
liked it I'm like because
dude that that girl was so [ __ ]
unique man like I've where I really
believed that I was like I need a little
bit of her delusion because like she
doesn't have the talent or anything at
all but look at her
look at her belief in herself she just
performed eight minutes of nonsense and
then she was like I didn't [ __ ] you
know I didn't [ __ ] like uh that was
just something I mean
as if we didn't know the audience as
everybody's mouth is like what the [ __ ]
is this girl doing hey you know that
that feeling that you said you've been
having of like that uh
that feeling of like the Imposter
syndrome side of things I feel like I am
that person sometimes like I feel like
maybe I'm just delusional a little bit
and like you said that was tight but was
it really and it's just everybody in on
this joke around me right now dog that's
like one of the hardest things that
we're learning to like move past because
like
I think people who are good at their
[ __ ] and I'm not saying that I am per se
but like we're always going to feel that
way and now it's just a matter of us not
getting in the way of ourselves right
that's why I want a little bit of that
[ __ ] delusion I want some of that
[ __ ] because they don't know that
they're [ __ ] flaming garbage they're
stinking up the whole [ __ ] room right
but and they don't know and they're mad
at everybody else for not loving their
[ __ ] but some of the most talented
people that I know have don't have any
bit of that and they just sit and they
wait for things to happen yeah I think
that's scary for me like when I see you
I'm like
what's the next big thing that he's
gonna do because I think for you as an
artist wise like you you actually have
like the whole package right because I
think like your angle is right the way
that you look your style your Vibe your
voice everything that you do is just
[ __ ] right and it's kind of crazy to
see like how do you know I'm 32 now
you're 32 right so like you're you're
two years younger than me so when I saw
you at the time like you were that that
backpack or mental step of like let's
sell a rap right and you're just kind of
trying to find your voice well you never
stayed there you've kind of you've
evolved every little bit of the way
which a lot of people actually don't do
I've seen a lot of people that were in
that same scene with us and they're
still that person that you started at
and it kills me and they're bitter
they're like people don't know what real
rap is they don't know my [ __ ] is tight
no your [ __ ] was dope but you didn't
[ __ ] evolve times change I see that
with a lot of YouTubers where they're
they kind of get in their [ __ ] head
they're like oh I don't get as much
views as I used to I get like you know a
thousand views here and there and I'm
like
well you didn't evolve yeah you know
what I mean you gotta change like Kanye
is crazy but you know every album was
different from his last one yeah that's
there's a reason why like how many
[ __ ] Platinum hits he's [ __ ] made
over the years over multiple [ __ ]
albums yeah and before he went crazy I
could recite all his [ __ ] lyrics to
every [ __ ] track dude yeah so like
that Evolution part is important I think
you've done that really [ __ ] well I
appreciate that so now for you it's like
you know what's that next step for you
yeah right now it's really kind of
focusing on
for one I actually have a lot of music
in the Pro in the works right now let's
go
um and the thing that I realized that I
have to do when I get into this pocket
because I've done this once before where
I had to kind of like start over
and it maybe is like a checkpoint for me
when I have this moment and it's
possibly where that Evolution comes from
but I for me to start writing lyrically
I have to start producing again first
because that's how I started making
music was I was a marching band kid that
fell into learning how to use fruity
loops and then started making music in
that format so now that I've progressed
in some of those ideas there's a lot of
ideas that I need to get out and so
I start rebuilding my creative process
through producing and making the sonics
and then after I have a bunch of those
done I can start writing stuff but more
recently I've been finding myself really
inspired to write again and get a lot of
the the words out and so it's now just a
matter of
I have so many different Outlets I can
use to promote that and I have to be
able to put all that together yeah man I
think that's really dope man like
reinvesting into yourself and kind of
the stuff that kind of got you started
into it right uh I don't even know how
the [ __ ] y'all producing this [ __ ]
hard [ __ ] too but I'm like in this room
and I just have my buddy like he's like
producing [ __ ] I'm like the [ __ ] hey bro
I just be stacking sounds
I don't mix nothing I'm terrible at it
like hey this sounds dope mix it for me
though yeah exactly make sure this
sounds better and and even just like in
the way I make like produce stuff
when I am making the beat I don't like
create this full soundscape from the
jump like I don't create it all
formatted where like the hook is here
the verse is here and the bridge is here
it's one big ass stack of stuff and then
I gradually start sliding stuff over
into their own spots that's looking
crazy dude I mean you have like your own
method to your Madness right and like I
think that's like the hardest thing for
me because like one of the I like I have
a bucket listing right and I just want
to do like
a small little EP right but then like
I'm stuck at the part where I don't know
my style because I haven't done music in
so long so I'll be in these like Studio
sessions and they're like What's your
sound I'm like all right I'll see you
guys tomorrow
because it has to start there yeah you
got to know like your identity as a
musician and it's so [ __ ] hard yeah
right and I think like you know kind of
wrapping back to what we were talking
about before it's like having to be like
a consumer first right and I think it's
hard for sometimes like people almost
don't want to be fans anymore yeah like
they're almost too cool to be a fan
which is terrible because you have to
consume the art first to even by figure
out what the [ __ ] you want to do yeah
and like I never want to be that type of
person where I'm just like too cool for
school
yeah I have always believed in the being
a student of the game always
um and I remember going to shows where
it would be the same promoter that I
would host for and I would be in the
audience and they'd be like why are you
down there and I was like because I want
to be bro I want to see this the way
that somebody is consuming it I don't
need to see it from up there today I'm
down to see it from right here so I know
what the product looks like from the
outside because I already have seen the
process and I've grown to love that
process now I want to know what it's
like to consume it and that was a very
important piece to me was being the fan
and being the student from that side of
it it's so important to be a fan of that
[ __ ] yeah like sometimes it bit me in
the ass where I've told the story before
where uh I I used to do these like
talent shows where I would like you know
judge and there was this kid who um
did this performance of Lady Gaga's uh
[ __ ] whatever whatnot right and
this kid did like the funniest
performance ever and I thought you know
this he's a funny ass comic that he was
doing like this Lady Gaga song in a
thick Chinese accent and I was crying
laughing gave this for all tens and I
looked at my other judges and they gave
him a zero and I'm like
dude that guy's [ __ ] bit was
hilarious they're like he wasn't doing
comedy he was serious and you laughed
throughout his whole set
I was mortified dude I legit was dying
so hard I was grabbing people around me
crying laughing
I thought he was doing a comedy bit
this
is how you get canceled
I'm laughing I was howling laughing dude
I gave him a 10. and I was afterwards I
was so [ __ ] embarrassed but let me
tell you how delusional this kid was he
came up to me after he was like David
let me tell you something
he goes what I want to do is I want to
quit college and I want to pursue music
100 and I literally looked at him I was
like no you will not I was like you need
to finish up college first and then do
music after because it's you know I
didn't tell him it wasn't going to
happen but I was like please finish up
college first he was like maybe we
should do a collaboration together and
then I stabbed him because I was so
offended
the audacity he was like we need to do
music together you and I were Asian
brother I was like I'll [ __ ] kill you
dude I'll legit kill you man get the
[ __ ] out of my face bro so
how did you end up making the transition
from music to Comedy which one came
first because I I Met You in musician
David so sexy by the way yeah you're
still saved in my phone that way that's
so funny man I I did music at first uh
for it was first and then um actually it
wasn't that I did comedy first but I was
doing music because like I said it was
like the only way I could talk to women
I [ __ ] you [ __ ] not the most shallow
reason ever right it's like why people
learn how to [ __ ] dance I think you
told us that then yeah it was the only
thing I would do and it wouldn't work
you know what I mean so it started there
and then I was like okay maybe I could
kind of do this because I was listening
to people like gay bun duck and Jeremy
Passion yeah right which is so weird
because I have conversations with them
now I'm talking to them on the phone
like yeah which is odd to me I was like
dude you guys I lost my virginity
because of YouTube
and they're such wholesome creatures
when I say this [ __ ] it throws them off
I'm like oh I'm a piece of [ __ ] guys
just to let you know like I got [ __ ]
because you guys so I I dove into the
Devil's Taco
so yeah you guys brought me astray so
okay um
I started doing music and then so there
was a moment my buddy Vince
um
I'm not sure if you got to meet him uh
Vince horror YouTube b-boy dude yes of
course so you know events like he used
to throw these jams and [ __ ] all sort of
stuff we used to do a lot of the a lot
of shows together because I was at the
same dance studio that he was at at
Capitol Roots well that's [ __ ]
amazing small [ __ ] world so Vince is
like so Vince years ago you know my
YouTube said he was shooting all my
videos like you know so we're like tight
tight you know I mean like he's like uh
like one of my closest friends now so
like we uh he had a show and it was like
a show where I was supposed to do music
and then I was going through this like
period where I I just didn't know what
the [ __ ] I wanted to be right and I was
like I gotta make a choice and at this
point I I had a music channel on YouTube
called acoustic soul and that actually
at the time for when it was open when I
had it before I actually deleted it it
had 100K subscribers so at the time when
you had 100K subscribe when YouTube
started that was like having like three
million followers yeah I deleted that
channel because I was like it's time for
you to make a choice are you a musician
are you a comedian because you can't do
two things you can't spread yourself so
[ __ ] thin and that's what I was doing
so
that same day that I went up on stage
before
um
I had my guitar and I looked at Vince I
was like hey I'm gonna do stand-up
sorry what I was like yep and I walked
up on stage and I freestyle like a 30
minute set
just did it and I killed it was terrible
but for some reason it [ __ ] killed I
don't know why I went off stage and I
was like I'm a comic I'm not a musician
like this is what I do even when I would
do music I would make jokes I'm like I'm
a [ __ ] comic that same guy I deleted
that YouTube channel
all right 100K subscribe and I said
delete and I got out of it and I started
up and I went back to the comedy channel
which was the Davidson Comedy Channel
yeah and that birthed that instead and I
and I took a bet on myself I was like if
you want to do this you got to stop
spreading yourself so thin within that
same year I dropped out of college I did
everything I dropped out of college I
said this is what I'm going to pursue
and I decided to do comedy instead and
then now I'm here I remember that when
you made the move it was a really
exciting thing and at the same time it
was like you it was me you and Stevie
Nader always ended up being like the
same yeah same lineups it was like they
related us somehow so Stevie Nader is
one of those other people like he was
he's a [ __ ] yeah he's still [ __ ] good
yeah he's still got some undercover
stuff that he's been working this
[ __ ] dude like I like I was
there was literally you two were the
ones I'm like just moved to LA with me
just somebody moved here with me so it's
not so [ __ ] scary what are you
[ __ ] that did you came only two
years ago like you [ __ ] you took so long
it was lonely out here bro broke as [ __ ]
you know and I was like I remember I was
like trying to convince Stevie I was
like bro you got to come out to L.A yeah
this is where it's at not because
Sacramento has thing to offer it's just
like this area is so competitive it
makes you work harder yeah like you can
be the biggest fish in a small pond fine
if you're okay with that yeah but
imagine what you can do when you're with
other people who are just as good as you
are maybe even better you have to better
yourself yeah and that's why you got to
go into like shark infested waters you
have to test your [ __ ] grit yeah and
so that's what La did for me I'm like oh
I might be funny out here I might be
talented on my music here and there but
let me come out here and I found out you
know I'm not that funny there's real
stand-up comics out here like they're
[ __ ] funny like they're working on
their craft day to day there's better
content creators and I've never been
that person
where even if I didn't this is what I
don't I think people are starting to get
now but back in the day people used to
think I was a [ __ ] hater because they
would be like show me a YouTube content
creator right and like do you think this
guy's funny I'm like no and they're like
why are you being a hater I was like I
didn't say I hate him I didn't say he's
not making dope [ __ ] you asked me if I
found it funny and I'm like
I like the content I don't think it's
funny you know what I mean but I would
use them as like inspiration like I like
Ryan Higa at the time I didn't find any
of his [ __ ] [ __ ] funny I thought that
she was corny as hell and but it was my
favorite content creator though and
people didn't understand what I was
saying yeah they're like how can he be
your favorite content but you don't find
him funny I was like because he's so
[ __ ] creative he's just not the way I
want to be great you know so people
didn't understand that so they were like
oh you don't like Ryan I was like I
don't know how many times I can't
explain this to you like there's [ __ ]
artists now who I don't really like
their music but I [ __ ] with them heavy
yeah you know what I mean yeah and so
like coming out to coming out here was
great to be around content creators like
that because it made me work that much
harder yeah if I didn't have that I
wouldn't have worked hard if I wasn't in
that [ __ ] small little apartment that
my cousin brought me into where I sold
everything that I had I had this Walmart
desk this box spring bed and I just
stayed in the room writing Vlogs all day
I wouldn't have done that back at home I
would have tried to marry the girl that
I loved I would have probably ended up
with her I would have given up all that
[ __ ] I worked in nine to five yeah but
coming out here makes you into a
different person not just here but
somewhere where you're uncomfortable it
really shows you what you're about yeah
that was a that was a big thing in my
move out here too is I mean I was in
Sacramento for literally 30 years my
entire life you know so I a lot of the
connections that I was making and
getting myself into higher places they
came with a lot of baggage and a lot of
like
it's really easy to get to know people
when you've been there for 30 years yeah
yeah yeah so building those connections
and networking isn't the same when you
step into a new space like this and I
knew that I needed to really test myself
in for one how I communicate with people
in How I Meet people how I represent
myself and how I build my own legacy at
this point
and so as I was doing that when I moved
here I found myself kind of in that same
position of just like you did really
well as a big fish in a small pond and
that was something that was that was the
common thing that everybody always said
it was like it's really big for you to
be the big fish moving to a bigger tank
now like you're finally gonna be
somewhere where there's so many people
doing what you do that that also means
that there's opportunity for you to do
it everywhere as well because there's so
many different places that need what you
do so whether there's somebody that's
already doing it or not there's a need
for you because somebody's looking for
you somewhere a hundred percent man and
that's true man that's why I'm really
glad that you're [ __ ] here because
you're super [ __ ] young and at this
point too in your life like you're gonna
need this type of challenge you're gonna
need to feel those moments where you
don't feel adequate and it's just either
that's going to make or [ __ ] break
you and I've seen a lot of people from
Sacramento come here and move back and
it's understandable it's hard out here
man it's [ __ ] difficult yeah but it
seems like you have like the right
people around you that kind of uplift
you and kind of feed into your Artistry
and that's what you really really
[ __ ] need man yeah because at a
certain point when you reach a certain
level sometimes like
things stop being collaborative and
people start trying to look for you for
like a shoulder to cry on all the time
but then you don't have that anymore
yeah it's like well where's my support
you know like you guys are looking to me
to bring you guys up but I need you to
lift me up too you know and I think that
you know I sometimes
get a little envious of people who are
like in that new stage because this is
like for you this is going to be the
most fun that you'll have
a lot the come up is the best yeah and
people don't understand that like that's
why people always say it's always Lonely
at the Top the come up is the best the
moments where I was struggling is the
parts that I remember and love the
[ __ ] most because all these small
little victories that I had it stuck
with me it was like I remember the very
first day I signed that YouTube contract
where it said that I was going to get
paid money for for making content that I
was making for free for a year it was
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get paid for this
and I remember how happy I was and I'm
like that's what I want to feel and
these are the feelings that I'm trying
to chase now even in my Artistry now
it's like not so much signing a new deal
or whatever but kind of loving what I'm
doing to the point where when I do
accomplish something it makes me feel
really good yeah and then you're in that
stage right now where you literally just
moved here it hasn't been that long and
technically you moved here during
pandemic you haven't moved here yet bro
I've been saying it's a blessing and a
courage bro I told people that was kind
of the the beautiful thing about it was
so we moved in November of 2020 which
was
from what I remember it's right when the
second lockdown happened it was like
when everything started spiking again so
as soon as we got here locked right back
down and so it was a blessing because
that meant that I didn't go out into the
real world to go Network and and go get
to know or get a lay of the land and
then come back and still have to unpack
yeah I got there couldn't go anywhere so
I unpacked everything got everything
situated so by the time things opened
back up my space was a refuge like it
was my space to really go home and find
some peace after whatever the day
brought whether that be good or bad yeah
and so it was it was a blessing in that
sense but it was a curse because then
when I got here and things did reopen
from the DJ standpoint of me wanting to
get out there and get gigs literally
every venue was on the oh we got to get
our homies back on first because
everybody's been out of work for two
years We're not gonna let the new guy on
today yeah yeah yeah and so that lasted
like a good six months even after
everything reopened yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it brought me that next level of
like all right so how do you make
yourself stand out without out coming
off like the really desperate [ __ ]
and it allowed me to like really make
genuine connections with people that led
to great opportunities that led us to
now sharing space together and being
able to do that with each other that's
why I really kind of you know for me
um
I always wanted to be the person that
like
had something to bring to the table
right I hate asking for handouts I don't
know what it is maybe it's because the
way that I was brought up but black
people didn't even know this like I
remember uh so one of my really close
friends her name is Geo and you know
Just Kidding Films and she's married to
my one of my closest friends Bart Geo
remembers this conversation that she had
with me when she thought I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because she was like hey we want
you to be in this skit with with us and
I said no and the reason why and she
didn't know this at the time but the
reason why I told her no wasn't because
I thought I was better or I didn't want
to do any sketches or film with them
it's like I haven't put my Foundation
down yet to the point where if I work
with you I don't want anybody to ever
say I knew you because of these people I
want to offer something to you guys so I
told her later on I was like it was
because I hadn't hit that point yet I
was like once I hit a half a million
subscribers then I'll know I have
something to offer you yeah I don't ever
want to take something from you and use
you as like a come up right which was my
pride at the time which I don't think
like most people should do but just just
how my personality yeah right and so
after that we started working together
right because
I just had so much I think it's
sometimes stupid Pride but
I had to offer something yeah right and
I think like for all the hard work that
I put in for coming into the city
leaving everything behind having [ __ ]
200 in my bank account
I couldn't go back to being like oh this
guy came up because of this person's
like what about my [ __ ] hard work you
know and I just I couldn't live with
that and it did work out that way where
it's like they're like oh this is a
collaboration between David so and Just
Kidding Films it wasn't oh this this guy
David so is a is a a cast member of JK
films that started happening when I was
I got too comfortable with doing just
kidding news I became a cast member it
wasn't oh David so would come on to just
kidding news and we he was a part of it
it was oh no he's a cast member and that
[ __ ] started to make me feel like oh I
[ __ ] up again I went back to that
person before where I was just leaning
on somebody else's strength instead of
yeah myself you know
hey man that was a dope podcast dude I
forgot how long this went on but um
they shot all your [ __ ] out that's what
you're here for
um so I am on all social media at
hellesus that's
h-e-l-l-a-s-o-o-s-h also hellasush.com
um which is currently being updated with
full portfolio of all the things I've
been doing including graphic design
video work and things like that so you
can kind of see the storyline of how
things have kind of gone down over this
time frame and the things that I've
learned
um it's really just become a portfolio
for my whole knowledge gaining
throughout the past two years really
um and uh that's really where you can
find me anywhere the streams are coming
back very very soon I can promise you
that the single patience with the video
is out now shout out to the homie Ethan
jovis we did a full day of just random
video shooting and it came out
incredible with adult really cool story
behind it so cool well you could catch
him on all of his stuff I'm gonna link
it all into the video and stuff like
that you guys are going to hear his
music throughout this whole video
anyways
um check him out on all platforms genius
brings every Sundays at 12 p.m and we'll
see you all next time